death and destruction after a Bomb Blast
at a candidate's office in beluchistan
Province these are the conditions
Pakistan's elections are being held
under no one has yet claimed
responsibility in the past beluchistan
has seen attacks carried out by
separatists the UN commissioner for
human rights has expressed concerns over
violent incidents ahead of this vote
there have been attacks on political
parties and candidates the UN
commissioner has called on authorities
to ensure a free and fair
vote we are here to present an election
where no one's life is under threat you
can cast your vote to anyone you are
free to do so the armed forces and
police will be present for your safety
ballot boxes and ballot papers sealed
and under high security with more than
120 million people eligible to vote this
is a huge task more than 990,000 polling
stations have been set up across
Pakistan National and provincial seats
will be decided in this vote but with
security threats in some areas it's the
military that's providing the security
but it's also the military that's been
accused of interference 650,000 military
police and paramilitary have been
deployed for this election under bakani
law there is no campaigning in the 24
hours before the vote and on Election
Day there are limits around polling
stations for
canvasing this is the bag with the
ballot papers they will not be opened
they are sealed inside and will only be
opened in the presence of polling agents
the elections will be fear the runup to
this election has been controversial
with the leader of the main opposition
Imran Khan in jail this is being viewed
by many as the most sensitive election
in recent Pakistani history
International observers as well as
International media present to take a
close look at how free fair and
transparent voting will be Assad bag Al
jazer laor Pakistan we're staying with a
situation in Pakistan zishan salahudin
is the director of the center for
regional and Global connectivity at the
Tad lab Think Tank he's with us live
from Islamabad a very warm welcome to
the program so Pakistan appears to be
facing multip IAL security threats at
the moment from the Pakistani Taliban
after relationship between the
government and the Pakistani Taliban
broke down a few years ago and now of
course separatist in baluchistan what
does all of this mean for the
elections it's not going to have a
tremendous impact on the elections
remember that this is not a particular
moment in time in which these attacks
and this this kind of violence has been
witnessed particularly in the northern
part of baluchistan and the southern
part of that's the other Province
bordering bistan that has seen in the
past a range of attacks and Terror
activities uh that have disrupted
everything from the polio campaign to
security Personnel guarding the
elections the TTP of course their stated
objective is to demoralize the law
enforcement agencies in Pakistan uh but
they have made it very clear that they
have no intention of targeting electoral
staff political rallies or parties their
targets will remain uh the law
enforcement agencies uh paramilitary and
military personnel in Pakistan the
bigger problem though is uh the ISP uh
you know the Islamic state is no longer
really in the in the side Guist of
Western media but in this part of the
world it's still very much a present
problem uh and they are principally
responsible for targeting the juif
political party valleys uh as you
mentioned uh in your introduction and
finally the third group that uh we
should be paying attention to is the
jamat whose stated objective is in fact
to try and disrupt the elections because
they consider that Democratic process to
be anti-islamic and against the values
and the ideology that group stands for
but all things considered elections by
and large should not be affected by what
has transpired the very horrific
incidents that have happened today given
the security concerns are as you've said
very very clearly very complicated
coming from multiple directions from
multiple organizations I wonder to what
extent the respon to this is joined up
between let's say the police the
government and of course the very
powerful and influential military in the
country I think all three on the same
page in terms of ensuring that the
elections happen without too many unto
word incidents some level of electoral
violence is expected because party
workers uh that are very staunchly
supportive of their leaders and their
political uh parties will inevitably
Clash but those are smaller skirmishes
that don't really result in loss of dam
loss of property and or life the bigger
problems are these three groups and as
far as these three groups are concerned
all three are misaligned with the police
with the military and with the
government of Pakistan by virtue of that
as Kamal said in his introductory uh
remarks that 650,000 law enforcement
Personnel have been deployed across
Pakistan the real problem here is that
the law enforcement by virtue of being
spread out so thin does then become a
soft target particularly for the TDP uh
at the jua and the ISP uh they are very
aware of this they've taken all
necessary precautions and measures to
ensure the damage is minimized but what
happens tomorrow uh is only going to
unfold as the day progresses and the 128
million eligible voters of the 250
million population of Pakistan go to the
polls yeah it's an extraordinary feat of
democracy if it's able to uh take place
without any uh major security threats
but meanwhile of course the political
turmoil in the country continues
following the rest of the former prime
minister Imran Khan along with other
scandals that have dogged Pakistani
politics in recent years how confident
are voters that this election will bring
about meaningful change and importantly
stability I think it is a situation in
which the sense of hope that some might
feel is undercut by the Practical
reality of what is happening on the
ground the former prime minister Mr bran
leader of the very powerful and very
popular Pakistan TQ insa the PTI party
has been handed multiple jail sentences
in just days leading up to the polls
resulting in a grand total of 24 years
behind bars which leads the vast
majority of his supporters to believe
that these elections are not free that
they are not fair but despite that what
I would say is that the fight is far
from over because even then Pakistan
being a very richly Democratic country
has multiple political parties that are
still buying for the so-called Throne
principal among them the Pakistan
people's party and the Pakistan Muslim
League Nas led by the three-time former
prime minister Mr naad Sharif and
inevitably for both of these parties
they don't really have the numbers to be
able to get Garner a 134 seats in the
center that's what you need in order to
form the government so they will need to
form some level of Coalition uh and will
really need to fight it out in the
polling stations uh in terms of the
votes cast cast for them for them to be
able to form a stable government and
that of course is the principal
requirement for any kind of stability
both economically and politically in the
country for the next five years okay
cishan saline many thanks for joining us
on
aler thank you for having me